ah
um
on set to change one thing
Marty go back in time
on set time where is that boy
it could be any said okay
uh well the I wish I could go back in
time
to win Michael J fox
forced me to do an impression of him for
him
I I wish
that I didn't do the impression for him
that I just went straight into my Doc
Brown because that would have been a
much better
re uh less awkward situation is your is
your Michael J fox Marty good
so here's the situation so I'm doing the
spelling bee show you want to hear the
story I'm sure tell me
so it's this is why it's good to know a
couple different Impressions so
I'm doing the spelling bee show
and I'm like I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna leave and my buddy is just like
hey uh I mean after the show the show
was great but I was like I just wanted
to go home and my buddy was like Michael
J fox is in the green room he wants to
meet you I was like oh [__] so I'm like
running around I felt like I just missed
him and I was like oh man and I turned a
corner and I'm just face to face with my
Michael J fox and he just saw he's just
like hey man and he's like I'm like hey
he's like I I hear you do an impression
of me and I'm just like oh [__] and uh I
was like yeah I'd do it but it's it's
from my comedy act and I'm just like
it's not I I'm not I don't want to do it
it's like do it like David Spade you
know he does one and and I was just like
I was like oh
he's like yeah Dana Carvey does
it's like okay I'll do it and and I go I
go this is what I do for my ACT I go I
go whoa doc you tell me you built a time
machine got a Mallory and then he looks
at me
and he goes he goes
you know my voice isn't that high
hey
it's playing with his family and I'm
just like
and then and then like I was like how do
I fix this how do I fix this so
instantly I turn around and I go
out I don't have my hands I do like my
best stock Brown and he turns around
he's like wow Jack and then his family
started laughing and then
and then it was okay oh my God I wish
that I could have gone back and just
like no no I'm not gonna do it Marty and
then we could have had that a similar I
don't know if he would have made me do
it just never no matter what never do
the impression for the person even if
they ask you to do it that's my advice